it is hard to believe that it's been
seven years since a dlc dropped for a
battlefield set in modern times
we've seen a lot of rumors about the
next battlefield game supposedly taking
place in the near future and it might
have highly destructible cities massive
weather events huge player counts
murder robots osprey aircraft and a host
of other things
and of course this has people excited
now we can't confirm it at this point
but what we can do is go back to
battlefield 3
4 and bad company 2 all of which are set
in modern times
and see if those rumors are even good or
bad ideas we have confirmed battlefield
announcements coming in june
and more coming from ea play on july
22nd
we also have a release date sometime
around october to december
so make sure to subscribe to the channel
and give us a thumbs up and we'll let
you know as stuff happens alright let's
get into it
let's start with massive destruction
which is a great idea
large scale destruction hasn't always
been in battlefield games it started
with the little pleasures like blowing
up a bridge in battlefield 2.
it then grew over the years as frostbite
engine was developed and
made less janky
going back to play bad company 2
reminded me that it was just the best in
that department like
hands down the destruction was organic
it was everywhere it was usually right
in your face
battlefield 3 on the other hand traded
better looking graphics and larger map
scale for less destruction that meant
the larger environments were full of
plenty of indestructible features
battlefield 4 returned to destruction in
a pretty big way some of it involving
massive spectacle but often it happened
far away from you and it wasn't quite as
exciting as bad company you might have
not even noticed it if you weren't
looking in the right direction
and some apps were less interesting
afterward the giant rockets and leaked
images do look like some kind of map
event or
major objective indicating a possible
return to battlefield 4
style that could mean parts of maps
being destroyed or just a visual
indicator that matches are getting past
a certain phase
what we're hoping is the next
battlefield game can harness more
powerful consoles and pcs to give
players the best of all worlds the
organic destruction of bad company 2 and
the massive scale of battlefield 3 or 4.
now you should know that it's been
confirmed battlefield 6 will be on
previous gen consoles so we don't know
if that will hold it back
at the highest possible level and we've
said this before but if we could start
with a map like
siege of shanghai and end with a map
that looks like battlefield 3's
aftermath dlc
that's the dream so in the destruction
camp we should now talk about extreme
weather events which
could be a pretty bad idea if we're
looking at what's been done already in
battlefield titles extreme weather
events like tornadoes could be
problematic from a pretty large number
of angles and frostbite engine
might not be up to the task for a
preview of that you just need to look at
parasol storm from battlefield 4.
vehicle physics for any kind of boat or
fast-moving ground vehicle in
battlefield 4 was pretty
janky and when waves kicked up boats did
not interact with the water well
it didn't just look visually odd but it
also made aiming kind of difficult
and i can't imagine having a tornado
nearby would help that
then there's player visibility which is
its own constant problem in battlefield
even up through battlefield v out of
title set in modern times battlefield 4
is probably the worst offender though
it's physically hard to see enemy
players against the background on a lot
of maps and you'll often die from
someone standing right in front of you
that you didn't see
i can't imagine bad weather and objects
getting demolished in front of your face
will help that problem
i'm honestly holding out hope the next
battlefield game just makes it easier to
see enemy players
finally just some quality of life stuff
here that surprised me i forgot that you
couldn't cut your parachute in previous
battlefield games and i'm not really
sure how that's gonna work with getting
sucked up in a tornado
alright so murder robots and in your
future setting is probably a great idea
battlefield games are at their best when
players can use tools in ways you don't
expect
and you bet you're the first thing i did
with battlefield 3 was go trolling with
the eod bot the amount of fun you can
have with modern gadgets really
highlighted what was missing from
battlefield 1 and 5.
ending a sniper duel by road killing
your foe with the uav
oh god you can't do this anymore can you
[Music]
even battlefield hardline's grappling
hooks and zip lines just opened up a lot
of possibilities
it's all about bringing back that
sandbox another aspect of future tech is
it allows squads to play together more
easily
i am a die-hard supporter of the tracer
dart in bad company 2 for its ability to
communicate targets to other people in
your squad battlefield 3
also had its own solutions for
communicating targets to your team which
is where we got the really fun javelin
squads from
wow look at that gorgeous
battlefield 6 will hopefully also make
some progress on giving more information
to keep squads together which can be
really hard to do when splitting your
attention between combat objectives and
where your team's heading
in the totally not confirmed leaked
images of the next battlefield game we
see some osprey aircraft
that's exciting because battlefield has
always had a problem with airplanes they
usually just head off into the sky and
do their own thing with
little impact on matches cute complaint
from old battlefield 2 video
but it doesn't often feel like jets
interact with the battle in a meaningful
way
they just do their damage and leave a
trail of butthurt in their wake
because of that issue a lot of the
medium to smaller sized maps only work
with helicopters
because they can interact with the
ground game that's why ospreys are so
exciting because they're a hybrid
airplane helicopter that can perform
both roles
as a plane they can ferry squads across
larger maps quickly as a helicopter they
can stick around and wreck shop on
objectives
it honestly solves one of battlefield's
longest running challenges with jets
which really just work on massive maps
and even then
only with skilled pilots and speaking of
skill pilots huh we need to talk about
controls
[Music]
mavericks re-engaging sir
aircraft controls in particular in
battlefield games are just not up to par
on a number of levels and have an
incredibly steep and unfriendly learning
curve yes people who put in the time to
master them can be god tier and i don't
want to take that away from you
if that's you but as someone who flew
helicopters a lot during matches back in
the day
i was at square one again crashing all
over the place just trying to remember
the basics
and that wasn't even trying to circle
strafe after spending so much time with
call of duty 2019's helicopters there's
just straight up no reason these
controls need to be that complicated at
a base level
there should be an easy default setting
and then the older controls for skilled
players
aircraft could also be very buggy like
constantly getting stuck in the sky box
or how in battlefield 4 if you inverted
aircraft controls the bomb sites didn't
also invert
so you had to play one aircraft both
inverted and non-inverted at the same
time
trying to fly an osprey with battlefield
4 style controls would be kind of a
nightmare for less experienced players
huge player count could be good or bad
it just
kind of depends in a recent investor
call it was confirmed battlefield 6 is
not a next-gen exclusive title
but the next gen consoles will enable
higher player counts the number being
thrown around out there is about 128 but
here's the thing
more players doesn't equal more fun and
boy did battlefield 364 player operation
metro or battlefield 4's operation
locker just remind me of that
it's an absolute show there are those of
you out there who like that mayhem
good on you but from a battlefield
perspective these maps just feel
pointless
players smash into each other with very
little skill or thought process
involved so how do you do more players
right
[Music]
you need purpose-built maps and the king
of this is still bad company 2 where
almost the entire game was built around
and balanced for rush mode that brought
just the right number of players
crashing together in
fun and consistent ways in contrast rush
really did not work in battlefield 4
when placed on large open maps built for
conquest so we're hoping that
battlefield 6 sticks with the good
tradition of purpose-built maps that
means conquest maps should be large with
every objective a set-piece that has
consequences
like older battlefield games if you
capture an area it should lead to
something
control of an airfield a bombardment a
tank spawn no more
caspian border you're capturing this
ditch because
reasons
in contrast rush maps should be
meandering and tell a good story
simply placing more players on existing
maps can go
very wrong high player count also ties
into the need for cross play
which is also a rumor going back to play
older battlefield games isolated on
their platforms or completely dead
was both not surprising and really sad
it can be hard to get a match or a
decent ping when players start to leave
one platform or another to keep the
healthiest communities alive
battlefield 6 needs cross-play and the
more the merrier if they want to add it
to game pass
another interesting angle that i hadn't
thought of until recently is
if these rumors are referring to bots
games have come a long way with bots
they can really improve the immersion of
a game like they did
in titanfall battlefield 2 back in the
day had full-on bot matches that some
people really enjoyed
we are very excited for the release of
the next battlefield game and to see if
any of these leaks and rumors wind up
being true
there are so many other aspects of
battlefield to explore like if hit
registration and hit markers improve
will battlefield ever get a proper
killcam how will classes be used or
changed this time around
the first official reveal is supposed to
be happening soon but in the meantime
head on over to gamespot's youtube page
and check out our history of destruction
in battlefield
alright thanks for watching
[Music]
you